that's it take your time take your time
it's okay take your time right here oh
backfill backfill backfill
golden you gotta get that back that was
colton underwood taking on the panama
jungle on cbs's beyond the edge all in
the name of charity and colton i gotta
tell you you are braver than me my
friend
yeah i mean that was intense you have a
fear of heights how did you do that um
adrenaline is a powerful drug uh and
when you're going up i mean i feel like
my whole body just sort of zoned out and
then you get to the top and you're like
what what did i just do watching the
show i'm asking what did you guys do
like this is so wild to me it's
celebrities of of course competing for a
charity of their choice but you guys go
through the elements in the panama
jungle you have these insane challenges
i am curious like what made you say yes
to this
oh i mean i wanted something fun and
competitive and then when you especially
when you add a charity component into it
it's a no-brainer i'm going to say yes
um i'm not the most outdoorsy guy you're
not no but i could put on like the game
face to try to get through it and i'm so
glad i did it's an incredible group of
people who came together work together
despite our differences
and supported one another and i think
that's what our country needs to see
more of what would you say was like the
scariest part of the whole experience i
will say the scariest part is for me at
least the lack of food and sleep i need
i get hangry yes and also like i'm a
diva when it comes to my sleep like
white noise air conditioning the right
pillow my baby blanket like all of the
things have to be right
and um it wasn't in the jungle and it's
not like you're waking up and like you
know refueling with pancakes and eggs
and bacon it's like i guess it's bananas
again
i think i ate over 200 bananas really
yeah oh my god that is so insane so i'm
i want to know did you feel like you
wanted to prove something to people or
even yourself by doing this show i think
it was just myself and also like weirdly
i just wanted to go have fun on a show i
i've all of the shows i did were always
so heavy and
there's definitely heavy moments in this
but getting back to my competitive roots
and like being able to compete and um
you know
what was interesting about this show is
i felt similarities to a locker room and
i've always missed a locker room of a
melting pot of cultures different
ethnicities races backgrounds like just
all of the
was there in the jungle and it was so
cool and it was amazing for me to
experience what can you tease about what
we can expect the rest of this season
you're going to start seeing over these
next few weeks the jungle starts taking
people out and it's not quitting it's
it's you know just saying hey i'm done i
can't i can't do this physically or
mentally anymore obviously i can't let
you go without saying congratulations uh
you are engaged you and jordan are
engaged i mean look at you two i'm so
stoked for you how happy are you i'm so
happy yeah he is incredible and we're
still working on like the boundaries of
him dating somebody that's in the
spotlight
so he every time he like he like sees a
picture he's like oh my gosh but he is
incredible and makes me so happy makes
me a better person um and
i'm madly in love with him i need to
know like how surprised were you with
yourself that you found the one so
quickly well i did i mean i went on a
few a few dates here and there and then
just when jordan and i hit it off it was
like oh this this is easy this is what
it is supposed to be and
to be honest with you i can always go
back and credit my days on the bachelor
of being able to like ask
the hard questions and tough questions
first and be very open and communicate
properly oh my gosh you're saying you
learned a few things from the bachelor
picked up a couple tips i picked up a
couple tips and applied it to my life
okay you know what that's why i watch
that show all right i have some rapid
fire questions for you about this
wedding have we picked a date yet no
location big or small
uh
big outside okay big and outside all
right what is the one thing you must
have at your wedding oh good kick
could we see a televised wedding no
that is that's a hard no yeah no matter
what the dollar amount is i've been
there done that with my life and there's
moments now that i'm keeping private i
respect that and finally we have two
bachelorettes this season first for the
franchise what'd you think of that and
also what advice do you have for gabby
and rachel i think that the franchise is
in a position now where they're gonna
have to keep upping the stakes in the
drama to keep the viewers attention
so
i think that's sort of why they played
into that and then for the two ladies i
mean i'm rooting i i always root for the
leads like i might not watch the show
and i might not be as engaged in the
franchise as i once was but i'm rooting
for them i hope they stay true to
themselves and i hope they get what they
want out of the show i love it i can't
wait to see it i can't wait to see the
rest of you on beyond the edge you guys
can catch colton on that wednesdays on
cbs
you